let me ask you a question on the on the
competition side you mentioned haters
and
do you think about this aspect of the
competition with the athletes is this a
great question and um the answer is no
uh
i'm
you can see that you could you couldn't
find two more polar opposites
psychologically than than george st
pierre
and uh this monstrosity on my left and
um
i've i've never said to my athletes hey
i think this is the
sort of demeanor you should carry
yourself with
i'm myself a very flawed character and
i'm the last person on earth who should
be
delving out moral advice to other people
um the only thing is that i you know of
course i believe some things are off
limits but as long as it's done in the
context of sport where no one's
physically attacking people or doing
anything crazy where it just goes
completely over the top then i give
almost zero
um moral advice to my athletes i'm a
jiu-jitsu coach not a preacher
alex i i if i can if i may
we we are entertainers
you know we're athlete for professional
athlete but we make
we make
a living because of people or want to
see us perform
same thing an actor or something a
singer
and a lot of the time
especially in the fight game
an event is promoted it needs to be
with emotion
love me hate me but do not ignore me
and
you know it
when it's authentic
it's done well i think me my personally
my my favorite fighters to watch are the
ones that are that
that that have
some sort of a bad persona i really
enjoy watching those guys because
they bring an emotion element into a
fight which is great you know i i feel
to me it's more interesting to watch
when there is an emotion involved
and i believe that's why
some fighters make more money than
others you know you know what i mean
that's the reason why we may we can make
a living out of this yeah they're better
entertainers but you're right the
authenticity seems to be really
important there's actually something
very interesting there um it's time to
break out some some secrets
do you know who
like like you think of george st peter
you think of like the highly technical
polished
martial artist that's just gonna do you
know
who his favorite fighters to watch
were
you'd probably be thinking oh probably
someone who's really technically
advanced
actually
it was mark coleman i don't know kevin
randleman and phil baroni
he used to love watching that was a
hammer house that was his favorite he
would love those guys
and uh whenever their fights were on
georgie watching the hammer house crew
and uh
it's funny what you said about how those
guys brought an intensity to to mma that
was off the charts have you ever met
those guys in
uh in their prime let me tell you it was
it was something to behold
and um i had this crazy larger-than-life
personality
most of the things i did made no sense
whatsoever but i mean technically but
that was their appeal yeah and and these
guys and george would love to watch them
more than anyone else you never knew
what what could happen with these guys i
remember when mark coleman won the pride
grand prix i was in my living room i was
jumping i was so happy i was like yeah
he beat igor
voor chef chin i was like
like to me it was amazing you know what
i mean
because of the emotion that they they
brought into the fight george is
actually very um interested by something
you said that normally when i
um
ask what is the appeal of a given
fighter um and what makes people watch a
fight you talked about the idea that
fighters are entertainers and that's
absolutely correct there they are
um
it's this weird weird industry where
you're
both an athlete and an entertainer and
you need to be successful in both
regards to become uh financially
successful insofar as
uh your favorite athletes
to watch at least were people who are
almost like the polar opposite of who
you are
um i've always said that most people
if you look at
uh say a million people watch a
pay-per-view event
what percentage of those million people
have a genuine
technical understanding
of what's happening as they watch a
fight
it's tiny
it's absolutely tiny the vast majority
of people who watch a professional fight
have almost no technical understanding
of what's going on in front of them so
how do they relate to the fight
what's the only way they can
it's through emotion
and so when they get a sense that these
two don't like each other
then they can relate to the fight
but only a tiny percentage of people
watching a given professional fight can
relate to it on a technical level
the overwhelming majority will always
form an emotional attachment to the
fight that's why when you see things
shows like ufc primetime they never
focus on
the tactics and the techniques of the
fight they focus on the emotional
elements the preparation the view of
their own family members as athletes get
ready it's always an emotional poll
because that's how 99 of the viewers
relate to the fight if i even think
about chess okay
if i have minimal knowledge of two world
champions
coming to to fight each other and
or match up against each other in a game
of chess i know so little about chess
tactics and
i can't really form any kind of
technical
appreciation of what's going on on the
board
but if you tell me that these two chess
players hate each other's guts and
they've got a rivalry which goes back
five years and they've said this and
that about each other in public then
suddenly my ears prick up and i'm like
oh okay this sounds interesting
um because i just don't have
the knowledge to appreciate what's going
on on the board in a chess game to be
able to
to appreciate the uh the technical
nuances of what they're doing so any
interest that i have in the chess match
is going to have to come from some kind
of emotional level because i'm just not
qualified to make technical assessments
and that's exactly how it is in the case
of both grappling and mixed martial arts
that's why the ones who evoke the most
attention are always the ones who can
form some kind of emotional appeal conor
mcgregor was the all-time master of this
i i believe also
emotion can be used as a weapon
for example i've learned i've learned
this from my favorite boxer is sugar ray
leonard
sugary leonard i remember i was very
young so i i watched his fight later
when i was older but i know that sugary
leonard
was the best boxer of his era to me
personally and i don't think nobody
could
beat him i think he was skill skill-wise
it was the best however
when he fought in montreal robert told
zoran
robert told zoran
made it in a way that
leonard became very emotional he wanted
to stand in front of duran
and fight a different fight that
that he normally does because he wanted
to show that he's a man
and he lost that fight which was a
mistake
so by by
then later on he beat robert holds
around in
quite easy you know the if the
everybody remember the nomas thing but
my point is
emotion can be used
in a way
that it can make your derail your
opponent out of his game plan and i felt
a lot of my opponent trying to do that
with me so that's why i never got
involved that was my way to defend
myself against
uh some kind of bullying to put like a
like a shield in front but some other
guy like uh
gordon he expressed himself differently
of course there's like language barrier
but for him he's better at
giving giving giving back that's his
he's a better counter attacker you know
that's the way you respond to to to the
aggression of a
of an emotional attack i think everybody
is different in that regard what's
interesting that john said that he
doesn't
uh study the tactics of this game or
maybe you're not interested in the
tactics of this game because it seems
like this is more than just being an
entertainer it seems like it could be an
effective part of the match yeah i just
feel like whatever investment you make
in that
is
it's going to get negligible rewards
first of all it's probably only going to
pertain to one match in front of you
rather than the totality of your career
and
whatever gains you get out of
psychological trickery and play
typically
don't last long you've raised an
excellent example with uh sugar ray
leonard he did fight outside of his
usual uh
manner in that regard but rather than me
try to tell
someone hey
behave like this before a fight i would
have been probably more forceful between
rounds with an athlete and saying no
you're fighting this fight the wrong way
and that would have a much
more beneficial impact on my athlete
than
psychological trickery before a fight
i believe another example of a
emotion that leads to failure as a
jose aldo against conor mcgregor
i think it was
it was uh on purpose that conor mcgregor
did this try to bait aldo to become over
aggressive to open him himself because
he's an excellent counterpuncher puncher
that's what i believe
and made a mistake
there's another great one
my match against cyborg
2018 no gui worlds where he didn't even
try to win he just like wanted to smack
me in the face the whole time because he
was so angry i was talking [ __ ] to him
before the match
and uh it was like the finals of the
absolute it was like the biggest
match of the weekend and he just didn't
even try to pass my guard or do anything
he just wanted to hit me in the face and
i was like sick i just won
it was incredibly frustrating it's
fascinating to watch like a grown man
sort of lose composure
gordon one thing i've always
been very impressed with you and that's
um
no matter how heated talk gets
before a match with you when you go out
to grapple you're absolutely cold
like i've you've never gone into a match
carrying anything other than just
cold-blooded calculation
and you've always been able to separate
very well
the idea of words and deeds and i think
that's always been one of your
one of your strongest assets a way i
often measure this is when a match is
over i will ask the athlete questions
about the match
and if they can't answer the question
what were you doing in the fourth minute
okay what was that setup you used in the
in in the third minute that got you into
the kimura lock if they can't answer
that that tells me
they were just fighting on instincts and
emotion but with gordon it's like a log
book you see uh
it's like okay in the seventh minute you
went for that uh
judy gutami set up for him from uh on
the left side
what were you thinking he can always
give an answer he's absolutely stone
cold